I remember one time I was at an event
Georgeville was speaking and George well
this is at Miramar Hotel Santa Monica
2000 and I'll give you the date exact
date March 20 something of 2009 and he
gets up and he says do you know
why these hook you know fish and cook
companies you know how they sell the
hook and why they have to put a warning
sign on it now because a parent sued one
of the companies saying you didn't put a
sign on they're saying you shouldn't
swallow my kid swallowed it and it hurt
his belly so they sued the company he
says do you know why so many parks in
America are being shut down because
lawyers go sit there and watch a kid
fall and break their hands and they're
suing the city and they're getting money
out of it because cities are settling
so they're saying hey get rid of the
parks we're getting too many of these
losses so kids are now obesity is going
higher these types of lawyers many times
ruin a lot of different good things so
you have to know like going back to the
same thing with McDonald's Hot Coffee
case
I I'm not comfortable with this man I'm
not comfortable with this